-Finally, guys, it is Monday,
a start of a brand new week
and I think we all could use a
little encouragement
to get things going
on the right foot.
With that in mind, it's time for
some "Monday Motivations"
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Monday Motivations.
-Hey, your hair looks
great today.
[ Applause ]
You're gonna have
an amazing week.
[ Applause ]
When you're fishing
and you throw one back,
it swims over to it's friends
like, "Guys, it happened.
I finally met Andrew.
[ Applause ]
When you zone out waiting for
your pizza rolls,
your microwave is like
"OMG, is he looking at me?"
[ Laughter ]
Your JV soccer coach still talks
about that gaol you made.
Well, almost made.
[ Applause ]
When you sit down next to
someone on an airplane,
they're, like, "Jackpot.
Hello future husband."
[ Applause ]
You didn't hear it, but one time
your favorite teacher
accidentally called you "Son."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, they gym
turned you away on January 1st
because they didn't want to give
people unrealistic expectations.